طبعا بالحديث عن الهجمات الروسيه على
اوكرانيا يبدو ان روسيا تستعد وبشكل مختلف
لما عرف بالهجوم الاوكراني المضاد فوفقا
لصحيفه التلغراف فان موسكو لديها سلاح
جديد قد يغير مسار الحرب وقد يجبرك على
اعاده صوغ خطتها للهجوم المضاد هذا السلاح
هو القنابل الانزلاقيه او قنابل التخطيط
هي قنابل جويه مجنحه ارخص ثمنا واسهل في
الانتاج من الصواريخ البالستيه وايضا
صواريخ الكلوز امتدادها وامتلاكها للاجنحه
يمنحها مرونه ويسمح لها بالتحليق على
ارتفاعات منخفضه اضافه الى صغر حجمها الذي
يجعل امكانيه رصدها بواسطه وسائل الدفاع
الجويه التقليديه غايه في الصعوبه طبعا
هذه النوعيه من القنابل التكتيكيه مجهزه
بانظمه التوجيه والملاحه بالقصور الذاتي
والاقمار الصناعيه ما يسمح لها بتحديد
مسار رحلتها تجاه الاهداف
بم قد يصل الى 120 كم يمكن لهذه القنابل
تدمير اي هدف على مدار عشره امتار سواء
كان الهدف متحرك او ثابت المسؤولون
الاوكرانيون افادوا بان الطائرات الروسيه
الحربيه تلقي ما لا يقل من 20 قنبله موجهه
يوميا على المواقع الاوكرانيه ما دفع كييف
لاعاده النظر في انظمتها للدفاع الجوي وهو
ما دفعها لمطالبه الغرب بانظمه دفاع جوي
حديثه وبعيده المدى كمنظومات باتريوت على
امل وقف هذه القنابل لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات